today we're gonna do some shopping yeah
i'm gonna try out item some wish i've
seen other people make videos on this
and uh this this is my nightmare like
garbage that you don't need but you
think you need right this is consumerism
there's everything wrong with the
concept right here in it no my my point
is i want to see if there's something
that will i will genuinely actually use
right i'll find what i think might be
fun and we'll see what i actually use so
i logged in using my google account
because wish forced me to and
immediately there's a weird pattern
right why am i saying that we got
two dollars get the [ __ ] out of here
there's no way that's two dollars oh it
gets a little more expensive but bro it
saved so much
all right i'm buying it why is there
like a skirt in between here what kind
of data have they collected on me huh
hey we got the bali songs they know
they know all right i wonder you know
how good are they gonna be this looks
used all right
okay all right ooh rainbow well
it's three buckaroonies like how long
can you get so is this all just drop
shipping like how does wish work i don't
get it uh all right this looks kind of
cool i'll get one of these
orange one is cool style a or b
golden or silver you could just say that
so these are the ones they show but
they're not the ones they sell okay
great a blue laser point uh flashlight
yeah yeah i want that i need that
obviously i need that a utility knife
ballpoint pen multifunctional
self-defense metal pen knife yeah
i need that three section telescopic
stick portable baton outdoor self
defense training training equipment how
is this training equipment so i've
actually looked into these unironically
just because uh
you're not allowed to use a lot of
self-defense here in uk yo you can smash
through bricks like you're not even
allowed to have an actual proper ballet
song listen you're not gonna [ __ ] with
me just forget about it i'm buying it
i'm actually buying it unironically and
then i'm gonna put this on top of it
gotta put that laser scope on my baton
that'd be actually
40 bucks why are you so expensive get
out of here
and then i'm gonna put this on it as
well i gotta have that aim on it hell
yeah this i thought just seemed like
actually dope because any time you know
you get an amazon package i just thought
it'd be nice to have like a quick tiny
knives i don't need like a big monster
killer knife i just need to yeah hell
yeah look it's not even it's not even on
him he's twisted his body it's flying
above him
this looks so [ __ ]
holy sh dude oh yeah lift that ass
14 bucks i these are beyond me why
people still buy these right this is the
dumbest [ __ ] ever yeah don't buy this
i'm gonna buy it just so you don't have
to buy it don't buy it this i've seen
all over tik tok wow that's so cool so
small becomes so large wow i buy all of
them police hidden attack flashlight
self defense
how would a flashlight turn anyone away
[ __ ] he's got a flashlight better run oh
my god what is he gonna do with that
sick yeah i gotta have that lamp spiny
tip too ooh so you can stab people with
it i like it a flashlight you can stab
people with i mean finger knife finger
knife oh that's kind of sick
will i ever need this absolutely none no
use your brain felix a cool magic fire
trick yeah i gotta have that i gotta
have that do they sell soft air guns i
wonder maybe we can find like the
shittiest ones no they don't they sell
night mission goggles for nine bucks you
got night vision for nine bucks i don't
believe it have to try it one thing that
kind of spooked me a little bit with
wish was that they clearly knew what car
i have because they were giving me like
attachments for it i might actually i
mean if they have like accessories see i
have the r design one right and they
they gave me algorithmic ones to like
replace these i don't know why you would
ever do that they look kind of trash but
lovely stickers
and only took a work item just as
described in smart on smart on why would
i do that why would i do that to my car
oh that's kind of dope i get the
official volvo one it's the official
right it's the official vulvar one right
it's vulvar right honestly yeah i'll get
that i'll get that what is this then to
lit up my registration plate why would i
do that before
after
but why is this a stronger light i don't
get it i they really want to show off
that you have the r design one i guess i
i guess i do yeah yeah i guess i do i
only have three minutes
that was close so this one is made for
my car i actually am very tempted to try
this that could be kind of cool maybe
i'll actually find an item that i yeah i
wonder what kind of massage stuff they
have i feel like this is the kind of
site that would have a ton of weird
massage stuff portable spa bucket
wow what the [ __ ] is this oh mine is
zero percent oh wow what a great deal
let's go
this is kind of thing that shocks what
the [ __ ] is it
two gear hot compress that looks
horrifying dude yeah i gotta try it
there's only ten left so i might as well
all right that's enough how much money
am i wasting on this 350 that's not too
bad so i know the thing with wishes that
they take forever right so i guess i'll
see you guys in the future when uh
boxing in front of me
i'm back it's been roughly
three weeks
i got my wish package
all right what do we got
smiling shark i didn't order this
what
oh it's the flash it's the flashlight
it's a shock light to kill
wow it's so incredible all right what's
the is there battery what kind of
battery what
[Music]
what
oh there's a charging port here
oh there's a charger and a battery
warning who cares i wonder how much
stuff you buy from china
that you don't know
it's from china right
instruction manual is in chinese nice
i don't know
okay that works
it looks kind of sick on the camera
actually the lens that lens flare that
hey
why you know my property
you're getting one it's not even it's
not even bright ah
you kidding me
ah i know that's not good for my eyes
but like
this this would not shock anyone
you kidding me
it's trash that's right it's trash
surprise everyone it's strange what i
bought from a cheap chinese website is
trash who would have thought
what
why do they make it seem like the
flashlight is some sort of lightsaber
like bruh look how many lumens
99999900 is so super bright
wow
that's why i could literally burn my
eyes out with them to rash okay
the goal of this video has now become to
realize if this is trash or not it's
trash
cool
money well spent
night mission goggles baby
oh yeah
see in the dark 25 feet that's a lot of
feet i didn't realize there were so many
feet hidden in the dark good joke thanks
i mean they look kind of sick not gonna
lie
i look badass with these
oh heck yeah
look at the child
like airbrushed child
why this feels like a product you would
find in magazines when you're a child
marshall mentioned this i remember this
you see in a magazine and you see
something like
glow-in-the-dark night vision goggles
only five bucks i can ask my dad to
order these and then you've got get them
and they're like they don't work at all
and here i am as an adult proving the
same thing okay here we go
i'm ready to try these in the dark
let me turn off all my lights
okay it's darkness
[Music]
what
what i can see everything
wow
there's no difference just so you're
in case it wasn't obvious there's no
difference
do i look hard now i need to get a knife
or something
[Music]
hell yeah
that's not good
all right night vision sunglasses i rate
them trash but aesthetic
10 out of 10 baby look at these bad boys
love them oh my god
no
how do i open this
oh bruh of course
i mean
it's tiny
what was i expecting i don't know i
expected an actual belly song are you
kidding me oh
i can kind of flip with it
you can do basic flips can i do uh a
rollover
making this one oh i couldn't
okay that's kind of if it was an actual
like sharp knife i think you could
actually be really dope like i would
have messed with someone that pulls out
this moves
look at this
a little trickier than i'm used to all
right come on thumb rule
it kind of works
there we go that's how it looks like
clean
[Music]
i rate this
trash trash again are you kidding me how
dare they
let me see the ad for this there you go
this is new
14 centimeters
that's a [ __ ] lie isn't it no it
isn't it is 14 centimeters i
guess jokes on me all right what's the
review thank you john i would actually
rate this one star but then again what
was i expecting at least it's kind of
fun i'm actually really excited about
if this works this could be not the
first non-trash one or the only
non-trash one i like how they have their
radioactive symbol on it
that's good right i feel like stuff like
chargers who cares if it's from china
right if it works i'll be very happy if
it doesn't i'll be very angry
don't mess with me china yeah i paid 50
i paid 50 bucks for that messy clean
much cheaper than other distributors yet
doing the job fits perfectly all right
job bar we'll see it better work if it's
50 bucks i mean are you kidding me i
listen i don't support buying chinese
garbage
buy
i don't know anywhere else made you'll
get higher qualities you'll make sure
that you're supporting countries that
doesn't have
human rights violations right you
shouldn't buy from china but if there's
literally no other options i think fine
whatever right so i hope this one works
all right here we are inside the volvo
this is where the charger is supposed to
go
that fits kind of nicely i'm not gonna
lie
okay so it does work pretty well the
problem is like it kind of sticks out a
bit which is a bit awkward and it makes
a weird noise that i'm worried about but
other than that yeah
i actually like this good job good job
chyna you did it anyway moving on we
have my guild suit that i paid 12 bucks
for it looks like that uh james says it
seems pretty good very thin fits perfect
really good product that had turkey
right on top of me i would hate for
turkey to be right on top of me but
here it is
beastmaster64
oh my god did i only buy the pants are
you kidding me
it actually fits quite well
it's pretty good
i don't know
if it's better than the beastmaster 64
one that i buy
you didn't see me
but here i am
i feel like they kind of trick you into
thinking you get the pants right
i assumed i would get the pants as well
but i only got the jacket so again i
would have to rate this to rash although
i feel very cool not gonna lie i feel
extremely hardcore oh wait oh wait
the pants are right here
holy crap
i'm sorry
there it is
there
you didn't see me at all
my son is going to love this
my wife's boyfriend is going to love
these i would assume that if you
actually wanted one that works you have
to pay a bit more right
like this looks like it really should be
one i assume so but i don't know maybe
this one isn't trash oh yeah i bought
this
well actually let me open this first so
i got this
this one i'm excited for this could
actually be good i bought this so i
could unbox
instead of having a giant knife right i
could have a tiny one to just open
packages with
okay
this is so trash who would put this on
their car
i mean i'm going to put this on my car
but who would actually put this on their
car i don't know where am i supposed to
put it on my car so i paid how much do i
pay for this garbage three bucks so i
can put double-sided tape where the hell
would i put the double-sided tape chyna
it doesn't come with double-sided tape
maybe i bought the oh i bought the grill
version okay so i'm supposed to put it
there
okay
uh
sure well i guess i'll have to try if
it's trash this um can i spin it
this is all right hey
i actually don't mind this
this is okay
oh bro it's such cheap quality though
it's over trash
but
it's okay i will rate this okay
it's so windy
how am i gonna fit this
i
bro it doesn't even look good it looks
[ __ ] dumb
yeah this is trash next up we have this
very cool i think this is a magic trick
i'm not sure who who you're fooling with
this item like
what the
what was this why did i buy this this is
two bucks i supposed to remove the
burning flame of the candle
magic fire awesome at night in front of
drunks according to ryan all right ryan
let's see uh the second best thing after
drunks which is a youtube audience
this looks real right
cool it didn't burn at all
ah
oh my god
am i supposed to keep this here
[ __ ] burn myself dude all right third
try if this doesn't work i'm giving up
okay
actual trash do not
set your fingers on fire with chinese
products okay
pro tip trust me guys next up we got the
laser laser torch i bought one of these
ages ago do you remember that it makes
me wonder if what i bought like
originally was some cheap chinese
knockoff or not i don't know i think
these go in here
and then i just screw this up
and now we
laser wow
good thing i'm wearing these protective
glasses because otherwise maybe i put
the batteries wrong there's no way for
me to know if i put the batteries wrong
because
there we go whoa whoa it's really strong
actually jesus damn that's cool actually
you see the laser even with my camera
is that going to burn that
this is kind of sick actually
i'll shoot right above you
[Music]
okay
oh you feel the heat
oh don't do it don't do that
[Music]
ah
i'm not i'm not playing around with
these chinese crazy stuff i ain't doing
it this
yeah
right
now i feel powerful not gonna lie
the last chinese product oh it's another
volvo's thing i like this i like this
thing i'm okay with it
yes
gravity link but it was supposed to have
the volvo logo on it that's why i got it
come on china you gotta copyright these
fool were you scared of yes
[Music]
look how dumb the logo looks
what is that that is not the volvo logo
oh what no this is garbage
yeah you put your phone
and it locks in oh what actual trash
uh this is going straight to the trash
actual garbage disappointed
all right that was it for this video
i think generally you know it is a bunch
of crap the only stuff i can imagine
keeping is the knife i think that's
legitimately it don't buy from wish
trust me bro guys
it just seems like a website that fills
this consumerism void like it it
algorithmically shows you a bunch of
products that you clearly don't need and
will never actually need and if you do
need you're probably better off buying
it from somewhere else so no i will
absolutely not recommend wish
and that was this video hope you enjoyed
smash like subscribe see you tomorrow
bye bye i have new merch represent.com
super happy about this so i think you
guys will like it check it out